do you smoke weed I do on occasion
what's your preferred mode my preferred
preferred mode is probably a bong a bong
okay um but I just dabble interesting
just a bong dabbler bong dabbler do you
have your own bong I do you have it on
you today I do not have that that is not
portable big ass bong have you ever been
high during work I have not been high
during work what if one of your
employees was stoned what what you do
what time of day is it High Noon High
Noon high noon so as a boss I think I
would have to ask us to go outside not
inside and then do you reprimand them or
do you like continue we get tacos tacos
tacos can I see your
eyes who is she are you high at work
right now no I'm not high at work right
now h